hi my name is carlos mayer also known as
mar139 i am a sculptor i'm a painter
legendary graffiti artist and i've been
challenged to demonstrate graffiti in
increasing levels of complexity
graffiti is a letter based art form a
sophisticated style of penmanship where
you give yourself a name
and you embellish it with signifiers
that are common in the culture this is
my interpretation of graffiti but
everyone has their own style level one
basic tag
a basic tag may seem like a simple step
but what we're focusing on is choosing a
name that we're capable of stylizing so
you have to learn those forms and those
gestures and that muscle memory before
you move on to the next level
i chose the name mare because i thought
nightmare was a cool name to have as a
kid who was
terrorizing the streets with my tag but
then i cut it down to mare
m-e-a-o
m-a-r-e
for the next level we're going to take
basic penmanship and make a design a
graffiti design level two finding your
own style we start taking the tag and
start embellishing it and adding design
to it giving it character
so something to consider about graffiti
style writing go back and reference when
you were a kid and you were learning how
to write your name in straight letters
you had to learn form and balance and
then you had to learn how to write a
signature so now that signature had to
have your personality and your swagger
you can take that concept over into
graffiti as well
one of the traits of the broadway
elegant style is that it's round and
long it would start off nice and tight
and small and round at the top and then
kind of open up a little bit more in the
bottom as it elongates and that's a very
unique aspect of this lettering form
from the late 60s and early 70s
in level one we used a basic stock cap
in level two
we use a fat cat now this cap allows you
to have a broad stroke when you paint
your name
now that we've learned about hand styles
let's talk about embellishing
level three embellishing a tag
there are many embellishments you can
add to your tag you could add stars
exclamation points quotations
underscoring lines with arrows that
point down you can even put force fields
around it with some of these elements
you're letting people know something
about you one of the embellishments i
like to use is the crown m
to me that signifies that i'm a style
master but also that i'm crowned up from
the ground up
now that we've worked on our style a bit
let's go get up
[Music]
level four throw ups
aka throwies
a big part of graffiti is getting your
name up everywhere you can with the
throw up or throwy i condensed my name
mere m-a-r-e to m-e so that i can
produce them quicker and faster and more
abundantly bubble letters also known as
softies you're supposed to do them
really quick outline them fill them in
and move on the numbers in a signature
like mine mayor 139 that tells you if
i'm from 139th street so it's kind of a
geotag before
the term geotag and technology now that
we've learned about tags and throwies
let's move on to more complex forms of
graffiti level five planning a
masterpiece today i'm calling this piece
a masterpiece because of how it's going
to evolve from one simple drawing on
paper into a magnificent painting it's
important but not necessary to draw your
outline it's always good to have a
sketch or something in mind before you
apply it to the wall in my case i drew
mine out because i wanted to have a
certain kind of symmetry and balance in
my piece today well the inspiration for
this piece
came from the first letter that really
set the tone i saw design elements there
that made sense to me the initial marks
that i put on the wall were just guides
for me and in order for me to have the
symmetry i was looking for i had to make
sure i knew where the parameters were on
the wall don't worry about perfection
because once you start outlining and
sketching it the paint dries fast so you
can coat it again
and keep coming back to perfect your
piece
so the guides are just there to help you
get through the process as you get more
comfortable and you start getting more
creative you lose all those guides and
you start really really embellishing and
freely interpreting what you want now
that we have our initial outline let's
start giving it color
level six the fill so once you have your
basic outline you want to fill in your
piece and generally you start with a
solid color or decide what color palette
you're going to use and then start
applying it accordingly but the fill-in
is really important that's where you
really start blocking out your piece on
the wall with the thrower you'll notice
how haphazardly it was filled in very
quick with the masterpiece
i took my time with the paint i really
wanted to stick i wanted it to be opaque
i wanted to show that i was
really invested in what i was doing one
of the things about
painting a masterpiece
is that you got to be prepared to kind
of have a
dance with the wall so to speak there's
all this muscle memory of course but
there's a flow that your body extends
with these lines it is a very physical
act
and requires some endurance and focus so
be prepared to have a very like
numb hand at the end of the day one of
the things with the spray can you have
to kind of master the pressure so this
way you can determine how thin and how
heavy your stroke will be
now that we have our letters down we can
move on to the background level seven
adding a background background painting
is important because it really sets the
stage for your painting it really gives
it a home to sit on the background gives
you a sense of completion with your
piece they really
allow your name to stand out for the
background force field i use the new
york fat cap which is a versatile cap it
allowed me to do a fine line but also
use it for broad strokes the colors i
chose had a lot of contrast between them
the reason i chose it is because they
would pop off the wall to me everything
in graffiti is subjective and
customizable it's about finding your own
style level eight blends
blending colors is a technique that
allows you to really give
form and shape to your letters you can
do gradations
from dark to light but also you can do
highlights that really accentuate and
give it body or roundness or even
reflection of a light source the
blending technique i used i chose to do
it very subtly so it gives the letter
some kind of volume a little bit more
oomph but not too much so part of the
technique i was using with the blue
shading has a lot to do with finger
pressure and i was releasing air out of
the can so i'd have a
softer
spray and also the distance matters and
at how fast you turn your hand when
you're spraying now that we fill in the
piece and
did some blends and gradients in it i
want to come back and give it some
design elements to embellish it level 9
design embellishments
i did some embellishment on the piece
with purple dots and designs that are on
the left side of the piece structure you
can use whatever you want there are no
rules there is a foundation but there
are no rules you can design
whatever you want however you want
within your piece this way
it starts to bring more life to the
whole production
level 10 the final outline an outline
can make or break your piece graffiti is
style writing so your letters have to be
on point it could be a great fill-in and
great colors but your outline is
important because it really defines your
letter structures it's the most
important part of the process there are
certain things you could see in an
outline that's not very good whether the
line is not straight whether there are a
lot of drips
so it's all about practice and making
sure your form is on point colors are
secondary getting your outline done is
one of the most important parts of your
masterpiece because this really brings
out your lettering style you can paint
all the beautiful colors you want and it
could hide your outline and you could be
judged on it by yes being a nice
painting but not a good style it's
probably the most challenging and
nerve-wracking of all because you want
it to be as crisp and clean and precise
as possible with the outline i use a
thin cap that's important because it
allows me to really carve out my piece
with a fine line and not have the over
spray or have a lot of drips when you're
putting your final outline this is where
your muscle control
comes into play this is where your
muscle memory matters
so that you know how to move
not just your arm but your body weight
along with the shapes of your letters
at this point i could walk away and be
done
but i want to add one more layer of
complexity to really highlight my piece
adding highlights is subjective it all
depends on your style hitting the piece
with the white highlight really makes it
pop it suggests something it suggests
that light is striking the piece it
gives you a sense of volume while it's a
2d object it makes it look 3d
there are variations on highlights where
you can do straight lines across and
smaller lines intersecting it to make it
look like a shine but in my instance i
did a fast streak with a nice hazy
finish at the end of it the nice thing
about giving it like a soft hazy finish
it gives it a sense of luminance and
brilliance as if it was a glass surface
level 12 the future of graffiti graffiti
is about getting your name up as much as
possible now with digital graffiti you
can spread your name and your artwork
throughout the internet around the whole
world you can now apply it on different
platforms from ar
to vr to 3d print and into the metaverse
the new york city subway system brought
my work to millions of people
the internet brought my work to billions
of people it has also allowed me as an
artist to expand and see graffiti in
very different form and it's really
important because now with virtual
reality
i can draw these graffiti sculptures in
space
and walk around them and articulate them
in very different ways that i couldn't
have done before
in traditional means so let's take a
look at this m
consider that we started level one
writing our name
very
straight up and down
and then gave it style
then we modeled it in three dimensions
in vr and output it for 3d printing and
now
i can place this anywhere i want in the
public space and it could be an easter
egg for anyone who finds it
graffiti is an ever-evolving art form
once considered an illegal art form is
now celebrated and practiced worldwide
you can find it in museums you can find
it in advertising you can find it in
fashion you could find it on the
internet the more you practice it you
can find your place for it and in it the
more you practice
the more you look at other artists the
more you collaborate with other artists
the better you will become
graffiti style writing is an art form
it's a personal expression
go out go get up
full disclaimer don't get arrested
[Music]
you